As a matter of fact, the universe always existed.
And once we believe as a beginning,
by just the transition from a contracting faced on expanding physically or the
bounce, the big bang side,
you can explain certain features of the universe that the big bang idea that
that was a beginning cannot think about if he is not a good future,
this is a sign of some sickness.
So Peter.
I'm guessing you are familiar with the big bang theory.
Well, I think you're talking about the 12 year running a Emmy award winning
CBS comedy, the big bang theory, but, uh, I'm not, I haven't actually,
I never actually watched that show,
but I am a huge fan of a young Sheldon, which is, I guess,
the story before Sheldon became Sheldon. But I don't know any of the characters,
uh, Sheldon or, I mean, I obviously know Sheldon,
but I don't know anything about the big stuff. No, I don't know anything.
Parsons.
The guy that played Sheldon who actually sort of became the star of that show.
Uh, and like you mentioned 12 years, it was the number one sit-com I wasn't,
I didn't watch it religiously. I did, uh, you know, I'm,
I'm familiar with the storyline and obviously they dealt with, with,
throughout the show, some of the top names in fizz, Neil deGrasse,
Tyson made appearances bill Nye of course famously, uh,
made appearances on the big bang theory.
And we're lucky enough to get some of the luminaries of the world of physics and
science. Join us here on what if discuss, but yes,
it wasn't talking about the show. I was talking about the actual big bang,
the big bang theory. Yes.
You mean the thing that the universe started from a pea-sized singularity
14 billion years ago give or take a hundred million years and we're here now
expanding from that, uh, from that explosion.
Yes. That's what they say. Uh, and again,
one of the things that we forget in that title of both the sit-com and what
you're talking about is the word theory. We,
we often sort of just take it for granted that this is an absolute,
of course these things are always changing.
They're always being revised as he was there at the time. Nobody,
I haven't seen a video. Right. Um, so like science,
it's always evolving. It's changing when we figure new things out,
we develop new technologies and this is no different.
And of course now the big bang theory, I'm not saying it's on its way out,
but it's certainly being challenged now by theories that are,
that answer some of the questions, the big bang theory,
didn't like the big bounce theory and cyclical universe theory.
The big bounce theory, meaning that we are bouncing.
Not like a bungee cord or a yoga ball or a
basketball. Um, but yes, I mean,
there is some sort of contraction and, uh,
or expansion and contraction thing going on again. Well,
so it's like one of those, uh, paddle ball fields. Excellent. Well,
this is the type of explanation you get when you, and I try to break it down.
So I'll give you two options. You could,
we could either continue this or you could actually hear the
explanation from probably the preeminent person on the planet working on the big
bounce theory right now.
I'm curious to continue with this and see how you use.
Yes, well, this I, she isn't, she is a theoretical physicist.
I am a theoretical theoretical physicist.
And I think in the end probably option a would be the, the,
the place where we're going to have more answers theoretically, theoretically,
on fire today. Um,
so our guest today for what if the universe was
bouncing is.
Well, it's Dr. Anna,
[inaudible] a theoretical physicist working in gravitation and cosmology at the
max Planck Institute for gravitational physics in Germany.
Her research is aimed at the most fundamental questions about the universe.
What is the mechanism that created our universe?
What is the universe composed of and how will it be changing in the future
before joining the max plunk society? Dr. [inaudible] held the inaugural John A.
Wheeler post-doctoral fellowship at the Princeton center for theoretical science
and spent the following two years as a research faculty and principal
investigator of the origins of the universe initiative at the Columbia center
for theoretical physics and Harvard's Institute for theory and computation.
Yes. Thanks for joining us today on what if discussed?
Oh, it's great to be here. Thanks, Richard.
Uh, not a small question, obviously. How did the universe form,
what is the origin of the universe?
And one could be forgiven for believing that, Oh,
we've already figured that out, right? I mean,
religion for years kind of had so many people think they have different origin
theories on kind of how we arrived here. And then science kind of took over, uh,
you know, four or 500 years ago,
ultimately culminating in the big bang theory being kind of what we've sort of
all agreed on is the origins of the universe.
But theory is really the key word in the sentence. And there's still a lot of,
to be determined, especially with your work kind of looking at it differently.
So I'll ask the question this way. Uh,
Dr. Esh in the beginning, there was what.
Um, no beginning. Um, excellent.
But what I believe is that instead of a bank that actually was a
bounds and is balance to customer phase of contraction before
to a phase of expansion after, and this expansion is still lasting.
So we are currently in expanding phase.
And the cool idea is here that all the features of the universe.
So the distribution of Mather it's geometric ecstasy today, um,
or three back and over generated during this phase and the universe contracted
down to small size and bounce back to our current expanding phase.
So we tend to always think of things in a, in a dualism manner. You know,
it's an, it's an either or for most of the things that we, uh,
think of like a King Kong versus Godzilla or Batman
versus Superman or a Superman, yeah. One or the other.
So, but, uh, with the big bang theory versus the bank bounce theory,
it sounds like you can't have one without the other. Am I right?
Um, no, I would disagree. These are really two distinct ideas.
So to one idea,
the big bang theory says that space and time really had a beginning.
And since this beginning it's always been expanding and always will be
expanding. And the other idea,
the idea of there being a big bounce preceding or expanding
phase, it says no, there was no beginning. As a matter of fact,
the universe always existed.
And what we believe was the beginning was just a transition from a contracting
phase on expanding physical the bands. So not only that,
these two ideas I competing, yeah. I really incompatible.
And the struggle is to figure out which one is the right idea.
So was there a beginning or was there no beginning,
but a bounce and the unfortunate situation today that he actually can figure
this out, but with using our mathematics,
using our computers or simulations and using experiments.
And as a matter of fact,
I would say recent work that I have done together with collaborators has shown
that the big band side, you can explain certain features of the universe,
that the big bang idea that there was a beginning cannot.
Hm. So it's more about the infinite versus the finite, I guess,
to some degree, right. Some degree it's true. Yes. Well, that's, I mean,
it's hard to get your head around and it's interesting because you hear,
you know, the cyclical universe theory, which sounds, I guess,
closer to what you're talking about and maybe is more compatible with balance
because it's, there is no beginning it's, it's kind of going in and out.
I've heard it explained kind of again, expanding and contraction.
And we've heard about the big crunch theory, which would,
I guess you'd have quite the six pack as a universe if there was a lot of
crunches, but in that regard,
if it's expanding and contracting bouncing,
if you will in a cycle, then, I mean,
it sounds almost like breathing. Is that, is that a fair at the macro sense?
It's almost like inhaling and exhaling.
It's not quite like that. You are right.
The earlier almost all ideas that involve the cyclic universe or the universe
underwent infinite periods of contraction and expansion connected by a
Basque. People really taught that it was more like breathing,
but that's not true for the kind of new,
new kind of cyclic ideas that I'm exploring together with my group.
So in the,
or the idea of what you are quoting is people told that after the bands,
so universe was expanding by a certain amount and then contracted by the same
amount.
But what we think today is that instead of what happens is that the universe
expands a lot more than it contracts.
And this is quite cool because it turns out that all the problems of the earlier
ideas, but the fact that people thought of the universe as a six pack.
But if you make the universe expand a lot more than, than it contracts,
then you can solve all the problems with what cyclic models and ended up with a
universe that keeps growing, growing, and growing and on the reason.
But we don't see in a sacrifice universe that that's the case is because we are
local observers. And so the officer rub would think this is just like breathing,
but it's not the case.
Ah, um, the,
the singularity or the primeval atom that they sometimes call it is, uh,
a big part of the big bang theory.
The big bounce gets criticized for bypassing the singularity.
Um, how can we understand that piece of the puzzle?
Oh, that's perhaps a misunderstanding because you know,
a singularity is not a good feature. Usually when a theory,
um, that we have in physics has a singularity to then be considered that as a
problem,
it is a sign of some sickness it's sign it's the sign that the theory breaks,
then anything contours the singularity.
So actually what people have been trying to do,
even in the context of the big bang theory,
to explain the beginning without the singularity, without the sickness.
And I personally, and I would say my colleagues to consider, uh,
the absence of a singularity theory, real advantage of the big bang theory.
You can cure the sickness of that.
Being a singularity by eliminating the bank and replacement, get a bounce.
I liked the, uh, the sickness idea of it because I mean, to be honest, it's,
it wouldn't be the first time that somebody brought up the,
the big bang theory in my life where I was like, so let me get this straight.
You're saying that the,
all the energy in the universe came from a piece size single air
and kind of what B, but the obvious followup has always been well,
what became, what came before the singularity? And generally speaking,
people have been like, wow, we, we,
we don't know which to your point is the breakdown in the theory,
you're somebody that also has an interest in the philosophy of science.
You've studied it, you've written about it.
And this feels to me where we get into a little more philosophical,
even esoteric because for the finite human being with our dualistic
minds, small dualistic, small dualistic minds,
the idea of infinity is just an abstraction.
It's so hard to get our heads around yet. It's a key piece of this puzzle.
How do we, how do we know this? Let's call it the unknowable and how do we,
how do we infinity?
Okay, that's a tough one because you know,
the question is if it's important to understand that
in the study of physics in particular, during the last hundred years,
we have uncontrolled situations,
then we just couldn't understand or imagine things that turned out to be true.
So take, for example, quantum physics,
it's really difficult to understand or imagine that a single electron can
pull through several slits, right.
At the same time and behaves like Vive don't don't understand it.
We don't really imagine it, but what turns out is that in the F in physics,
we very often encounter situations when we have to live with things,
we have to accept things. But the previous, I taught not to be true,
not to be imaginable. And I believe it is similar with the universe. You know,
if an experiment or if, if,
if we invent theories that tell us that the universe might be infinite,
and we find experiment that show us that that really is the better explanation
than assuming a finite universe.
Then we probably be our first have to live with it without truly understanding
or, or imagining it just by the way that that's the better explanation, uh,
being taught us by experiments. So this is a strange situation.
Yeah. And it's,
it's like a lot of you hear about some people talking about no time and space,
and although I can say, okay, I can,
I can understand what you mean,
but I can't understand no there's time and space. Like,
it just feels like something that's such a, an integral part of this existence,
but the lack of time is just something so abstract for our human minds.
Or at least my human mind, I am in space. There is time. Yes,
I would say as well, but these are obviously, uh,
some bigger questions, which we will, we will follow up with you, uh,
after we take a little break here, because there's,
there's certainly more to get to. Um, but we really, I mean,
thanks for taking us through this particular, in the beginning scenario,
or at least one of the scenarios of in the beginning,
where can people follow your work right now? And what do you have coming up?
Because it sounds like you're on the cusp of some pretty big game-changing
theories.
I hope so. Certainly, uh, this is pretty simple. So we have a website,
my group has a backside. It is also simply it's called advancing cosmology.com.
And there you find me, my bio links to my personal website.
Um,
the people I work with and that descriptions are papers that they put out and
perhaps most interesting for, for, for the viewers, uh, is that we have,
there was a links to videos and videos, uh,
that some of them are quite accessible for,
for people who don't everyday and every night work on the bands.
Like, like, like Peter and I.
Small brain people.
Um, well, if you like this episode, and I don't know why you wouldn't, yeah.
Maybe you'd like to dig a little bit deeper and you can,
because we're going to go a little bit deeper on our extended audio podcasts.
Yes. Which I'm in and who knows by the end of this, we might have, uh, we,
we might've figured out, uh,
how the universe started and perhaps more importantly,
where is the universe going? Maybe.
We're on the cusp of, of solving. It feels like.
We are, but, uh, you know, probably in the next 20 minutes,
we'll probably just scratch the surface. Uh,
Dr. [inaudible] thanks for joining us today on what if discussed?
Thanks so much. Thanks. So, uh,
yeah. Wow.
I don't know where to start. That's.
I can't know where to start because as Dr. Yesh says, there's no beginning,
and there is no end, right.
That is perfect. Which again, it's really hard to get your head around.
I learned a lot and I love, I love how she describes what she's working on,
but there's a reason why there's only a few people in the world that are working
on these types of things,
because they have the minds that can sort of even deal with the infinite
me. On the other hand, it ends up being kind of more questions than answers.
Yeah. Well, uh, here's the thing.
The thing is that we have more questions and we'll get more answers on the other
side. On the other side, if you liked this interview and you want to learn more,
maybe you want to learn infinitely more.
Maybe you want to contract a little bit and not learn on fire either way.
Why don't you click on the link below and that'll take you to the extended audio
version. Now, if you're already listening to the extended audio version,
don't go looking for a link. Cause there is no link. Just keep listening,
just keep listening. That's all there is to it. Uh, we'd like to thank Dr.
[inaudible] again, and please join us again next week on.
What if disgust.